le but de ce film était définitivement
de monter la barre autant que possible, il y
avait beaucoup de personnages que les
gens dissipent en voyant Kirk et Spock
os Scotty son coche et Sulu
je suis plus excité je peux vous dire l'
action dans  ce film l'échelle du
film est à des années-lumière au-delà de ce que nous avons fait
dans le premier
film c'était assez magique de voir ce qu'ils
ont pu créer cette fois je pense que
c'est incroyablement beau le mot de
continuer à revenir à juste implacable
il y a une chose  après l'autre après l'
autre après l'autre c'est le genre
de falmouth 3d a été fait
sans aucun doute l'imax et la 3d de
celui-ci, je pense, donnera aux téléspectateurs encore un autre
niveau d'excitation ce film a été l'
expérience la plus amusante et la plus stimulante que
j'ai eue  c'est comme tout ce que j'ai
jamais fait dans un film